يستخدم اذا اليورانيوم المنظم في تقويه
وتعزيز الدروع بكثافه تعادل ضعفين ونصف
كثافه الفولاذ العادي يستخدم اذا هذا
النوع من الدروع مثلا في دبابات ام 1
برامز ومدرعات ام توبرادلي وفي طائرات اي
عشره ثاندر بولت اثنين استخدامه الاكثر
جدلا في القذائف التي تمكن من اختراق
الدبابات والدروع بسهوله اكبر حيث تصطدم
قذيفه اليورانيوم المرطب بالهدف لتحترق
ذاتيا في درجه حراره عاليه تنبعث منها
جزيئات اليورانيوم متناهيه الصغر في
الغلاف الجوي عاده اذا ما يستخدم
اليورانيوم المنظم في القذائف التي تطلق
من دبابات تشالنجر البريطانيه وابرز
الامريكيه بالاضافه الى دبابه ليبارج
الالمانيه وفقا لمعهد الامم المتحده لبحوث
نزع السلاح لا يمكن اعتبار ذخيره
اليورانيوم المنظم اسلحه نوويه لانه لا
يفي بالتعريف القانونيه للاسلحه النوويه
او الاشعاعيه السامه او الكيميائيه في
المقابل يرى خبراء البيئه والصحه العامه
وجود مخاطر في استخدام مثل هذه القذائف
بسبب استنشاق الهواء المنطلق عند الاصطدام
بهدف مدرع اضافه الى سميت اليورانيوم
المنظم اذا تسرب الى التربه على مر السنين